do you regret getting involved with the
Trump campaign I absolutely do not
regret joining the Trump campaign I
think the Trump campaign was a historic
campaign I think that campaign probably
changed history forever
especially at modern American political
history and we're seeing the effect of a
trump presidency around the world today
neither you personally you committed a
crime and you went to jail for it that's
true that's true but that doesn't affect
their negate what I was doing on the
Trump campaign I pled guilty to lying
and I explained the logic behind that
decision when you're looking at so many
years in prison mounting legal bills
being basically isolated from the world
and having prosecutors demanding insane
things from you at a 29 years old you
know that adds into the calculus of your
decision so a committed guilt because
you were young no I didn't admit guilt
but I just want the world to know she
did it make it right of course I
admitted guilt I pled guilty I went to
jail for 11 nights over it but there
were many factors that went into that
decision you've said you had street cred
in prison because of your links to
Donald Trump was it a bit of a hero's
welcome then for you let's remember
where I was actually in prison it was in
Oxford Wisconsin which is a pleasant
place in Mid America 800 people live in
that city
most of them support the president's
including most of the guards there and I
guess the inmates saw me as a bit of a
political celebrity going in there and I
mean these inmates this isn't like the
movies I was in there with doctors with
lawyers with businessmen who had either
you know conducted wire fraud or some
sort of you know white-collar crimes I
wasn't in there being attacked or
fighting people and so what do people
say to you inside of prison uh you know
I had a couple nicknames in there and
you know funny things like Pappy and
your Pappy or the man your Papa Doc you
know can you help me with my jail
sentence can you talk to the president
for me I mean there were some funny
comments like that when you get out can
you please tell the world about the
situation here
with how inefficient it is what makes
you think you deserve a pardon I never
actually thought I deserve one or I
never had an expectation to deserve one
my lawyers are the ones who filed this
pardon application because they believe
that's in my legal interest as their
clients eject
maybe if I divide do I deserve one I
simply want the world to hear my side of
the story to hear the truth and whether
the President ends up pardoning me or
not that's up to his discretion it's his
decision if he gives me one of course I
would accept it I'd be honored to accept
that but do I have an expectation no and
am i hoping for one No
do you think it feels a bit premature
and perhaps naive so soon after you
admitting guilt and serving time in
prison and this is in relation to
communications about a foreign
adversary' if you suddenly to be granted
forgiveness by the President of the
United States what I didn't I did not
hand write this part an application I
have a great legal team who thinks it's
in my interest to do that so I guess the
onus and the burden is on them for
submitting it when they did and they
probably have a reason for submitting it
when they did so is this book not just
in an elaborate way for you to try and
walk back that guilty plea no actually
what actually before I even went to
prison I was actively and openly
discussing withdrawing my guilty plea
that this is public knowledge for months
actually before I even went to jail
because of the new facts that had
emerged about my case recently that I
did not know about at the time I pled
guilty you say you're loyal to your
country you also say that the FBI asked
you to wear a wire but you said no if
you are a patriots why wouldn't you want
to help in an investigation into
possible communications with a foreign
adversary I'm not the professional I'm
not the intelligence operative I'm not
the investigator I'm the person who is
there to give the information for the
FBI to conduct a thorough investigation
to and use their surveillance tactics
their ways and methods
of finding out if what I'm telling them
is credible or not the president has
said that he believes that robert muller
acted honorably you've described robert
mullahs investigation as a hoax but 34
individuals were charged and three
companies you think that represents a
hoax t the basis and the foundation of
the investigation were corrupted and
there's overwhelming evidence that
explains why in congress now are is
holding new investigations into some of
these people who conducted this
investigation who started this
investigation many of the people have
been fired they're currently under
investigation themselves or they've been
demoted from their former high positions
they once had under the obama
administration so do i think he
conducted a thorough investigation he
certainly conducted a thorough
investigation into me he knew everything
about me did he act honorably i
personally don't think he did what was
at night when you spoke to Robert
manners team so imagine this you're 29
years old you're enjoying a wonderful
vacation in Europe with your then
girlfriend in Greece and Italy and
you're at the peak of your life and then
you are flying back to the United States
where you're expecting a job where I was
expecting a job and now with the White
House but with a news channel and you're
violently arrested at an airport you
don't understand what you're being
arrested for initially and you're then
in front of a magistrate who's telling
you you're looking at 35 years in prison
without quite understanding your
situation you're then in front of a
group of Starr prosecutors the Muller
team they're very intimidating you don't
want to get on the wrong side of these
people I certainly didn't want to it was
confusing Robert Malley concluded there
was no collusion no conspiracy that is
good news for America he was also able
to charge those who had committed crimes
that's also good to see just as being
done isn't it if the investigation was
justly
started and was and the foundations were
not corrupted as now the president and
his top allies in Congress are
suggesting and I am suggesting myself I
agree with you but when an investigation
should have never started in the first
place as the president's own lawyer
stated yesterday then Justice I don't
think was served I think people's lives
were destroyed in many ways fertilis I
am not a victim I'm a fighter I am
fighting back and I have a beautiful
life with my wife in California now and
we're focusing on many different
projects and I'm young enough to
actually recover other people who are in
their 70s in their 60s like Michael
Flynn or Roger stone or some of these
other people caught up in this who have
families already they probably had taken
their toll taken on them was probably
irreparable and very damaging